قال تحقيق لصحيفه ول ستريت جورنال
الامريكيه ان غاره جويه اسرائيليه على
مخيم جباليا في قطاع غزه في الحدي من
اكتوبر تشرين الاول الماضي قتلت احد قاده
حماس لكنها ادت الى مقتل عشرات المدنيين
ايضا واضاف التحقيق ان اسرائيل قررت عدم
تحذير المدنيين في المنطقه من غاره جويه
وشيكه عبر رسائل هاتفيه خوفا من منح
مسلحين وقتا للاخلاء وذكر تحقيق ول ستريت
جورنال ان الجيش الاسرائيلي القى على
الاقل اثنتين من اكبر القنابل في ترسانته
بدلا من استخدام ذخائر اصغر حجما واشار
التحقيق الى ان مزيجا من التكتيكات
المتعمده والعواقب غير المقصوده اسهم في
واحد من اكثر الانفجارات دمويه في حرب غزه
ونقل تحقيق ول ستريت جورنال عن مستشار
سابق
للامن القومي الاسرائيلي ان حماس تشعر
الان بالثقه الكافيه لرفض اي صفقه لا تحقق
لها النصر بشكل مباشر وان الظروف التي
تعمل في ظلها القوات الاسرائيليه اصبحت
اكثر صعوبه مما كانت عليه في الماضي بينما
تحسنت الامور بالنسبه لمقاتل
حماس